yeah so I'm going to do a prelude to me
house talk later so I'm going to
celebrate the subjects financial
algorithm pletion problems i'm going to
slowly define what i mean by that and
then what I'm going to say there so let
me first apologize to these ones who
already helped me with this topic so I'm
not in some sense this topic will be a
bit about a slightly stale bread I mean
the lightest result i'm going to talk
about is something like a perdonar hive
in early 2014 so this is not that super
fresh as for example today morning but
talk when there was like board stock of
something that was Justin to stock and I
hope so I think so and then but that's
first as a prelude to me cuz and then
this in some sense as I was call it like
a success story or something like we
really managed to get all the almost all
the positive result upper bounds like
that we think that are tight now we're
waiting for the lower bounds and that's
what we all will be talking about but in
successfully think that we get most of
what you can gather get almost all we
can get in terms of upper bounds in
there like find grandparent right
setting cuts in some sense sort of
success story of course there's like
okay there are some disclaimers but
let's go on okay so first let's define
what we are interested in and now at me
now start research sort of an elevator
pitch about graph modification problems
when they are interesting and why a
particularly paralyzed complexity fbt
our girls are very good framework to
work with them so let's think of like
some graph representing a risotto for
your experiments so the usual the usual
x example here is that ok every note
some some observation or some object and
edge corresponds to whether we think
this is similar object or the same
object or not and and you think okay if
this like measurement of objects and
energy whether we think this is at the
same object or similar object then they
somehow should look like cluster graph I
mean they should form cliques like
similar objects or form cliques and not
similar objects to be like completely
separate it should be no edge between
them so the graph of such an experiment
or such observations should look like a
cluster graph disjoint union of pigs but
of course in the last hour theory
that's behind this shadow under our
theory but of course we have got some
error in measurement so that means that
I mean some edges present which
shouldn't be present there I mean some
there's some force policy for force-
some of this edges here are missing I
mean the red edges were are the missing
I just ok and of course if we are good
scientist with believe that we've
developed a very good and experiment we
believe that there are only few errors
in our hot measurement and now we want
to fix these errors i mean we want to
detect I mean we want to say that ok I
works or experiment data matches our
theory and watch the sour cherries I
want to detect these few errors and fix
them I say ok this is a console graphs
and we can say that the number of
modifications is a parameter I mean
that's the I mean that we say in their
PT of standard I mean if you think I
have PT that this is like the principal
you have got this big instance with this
small parameter and you want to solve
the instances with small parameter and
big instances but with small parameter
then having like a big experiment with
only a few errors that very well the
negative experimenter like idea how
where this should be applicable where
with which type of instances should we
be able to solve and efficient ok so
that's the gratification promise and we
are particularly interested in this talk
about only like one side the terror that
means that there can be missing edges
but there are no extra just so we can
only add the edges so in such as you can
think of like we won't add a few edges
to the graph to make it consistent with
your theory or to fall into some graph
class that represents your vertical
expectations and ok in our running
example of like cluster graph I believe
everybody can develop a very quick or
innovator algorithm for completing
across the graph that's not very
sophisticated but let's keep with this
example so you can think of this but I
want how to convey the idea that you can
think of this graph modification problem
store some craft class in two different
ways so you can think of for example
cluster graphs you want to complete so
that every connected component is a
click and that's like it success the
positive way the thinking like was the
structure of the graph but you can also
think about the bad guys on what breaks
you what stops you from being a classic
well the cluster graph is a graph that
doesn't contain any p3 and you like
three vertex path as an induced sub
graph so I can think like I want to kill
or induced sub graph that belong to some
set of forbidden suburbs or me mal
forbidden suburbs for my graph class
second thing in terms are either I want
to build clicks or I want to kill or
beef ribs there are like two different
ways of thinking and actually if you
start working with this one's like they
lead to very different types of things
or like types of algorithms okay so
let's let's go there on their side now
that are for like for vertex addition
problems that you want to delete
voltages to get some graph class there's
a noun dichotomy saying that essentially
everything you want to solve this and be
hard we're for completion problem is
highly unclear oats stature IP political
time survivor animals NP hard okay so
decreased so here we worked with the
cluster graphs and as probably most of
you already noticed adding edges
together class or graphs not the most
exciting problem but there are few graph
classes might slightly similar to the
cluster graphs that actually turns out
to be quite interesting and challenging
and these are digit of classes some of
them may be familiar to follow them not
i'm not going to define most of these
crosses you can always tricking writers
apart from that the interesting ones for
us will be the chordal graph interval
graphs particular in this talk so the
code the interval graphs I think already
Daniel defined very quickly in the
morning that are the intersection graph
of intervals on the line so every vertex
corresponds to an interval and to
interpret versus energizing these
intervals overlap and coral you can
think of the same inside the inside the
tree so if you've got some big tree and
the vertices correspond to sub trees or
you can think in the other way around as
the graph such that there are no induced
cycles apart from triangles inside ago
so every cycle has got some colors
inside its trunk right okay and why
these classes are interesting especially
from the point of view of completing
them because in some sense completing a
grafter chordal graph or completing
after an interval graph corresponds to
having a tree decomposition or public
composition of the graph so for example
you can think of like heavier fiber
graph you have your tree decomposition
and now if you turn every back into a
click
that this became a chordal graph so you
can think like of having a puff
decomposition or a tree decomposition as
a completion to cartographer commission
to a telegraph and the weaves of this
decompositions corresponds to the
maximum size of a clicking in the graph
in a cartographer interval graph you go
up there and they're like other measures
like the vertex cover size three depth
and bandwidth corresponds in design
science the proper interval trigger
perfect interest holographs you could
make this assumption and like this is
like this field I usually means that
there's like plus minus one error I mean
because somebody subtract one from
Sharif from the size of the bag that
means that there's a minus one up there
or something okay so that's the classes
we are going to study here but let's
start from so now i'm going to assess
sorry or liked give you idea how to
approach such problems completion
problems so let's start with like class
similar to this craft classes but
slightly different sorry different okay
sorry i forgot about this time so i'm
going to look at F of K in there fpt
running time so this is their the
running time where I'm going to look at
the function of K what's the optimal one
mainly because that's the thing that we
can have we had in a few relation
there's very tight bounds for a number
of problems with the optimal function f
of k and we don't have any now I mean we
can try to get good linear real good
Paulina me about factors but we I mean
except for the few polynomial recent
results we don't have any good bounce so
I mean this this talk is about Australia
of Christ studying polynomial factors
also and I study but I'm going to focus
on five of kinda stock ok so I'm going
to look first of the speed graphs split
grass or graphs similar dynamic simpler
more restrictive case and the prep than
the ones we talked previously till the
graph such that you can decompose the
vertex at inter click this is a click
and the independent set and there are
some ads which are connections between
these two parts and if you look at the
forbidden subgraph definition I mean
which guys are forbidden it turns out
that this exactly corresponds to graph
that do not contain any cyclone four
vertices five vertices all right to
cater to cato's are just too / alleges
as a new sub graph so these are this
computer and now ok so i want to add
edges to have a speed graph which means
that i want to add edges to kill all
such suburbs
new sub graphs which means that I can
okay is my graphs please graph well not
here is stiffer for example okay given
Safari you can add this edge or this
edge to kill took in it so it burns into
two directions for see five that's five
directions for it okay to this for
directions and general it was like
formalized in the 90s that I mean in all
this graph classes that you guys got a
finite number of 4 million subgraphs
what you do you look if you're grab
blooms your graph does not you find one
of the minimal forbidden your sub graph
and you branch into bounded number of
ways how to kill him and that's like see
to decay FPT algorithm is now we even
know that that means that there is like
2 better than to the power n exponential
time algorithm okay so that's the simply
bunch of surgery and it works for a
number of graph passes from the previous
slide at least it killed four of them
are I mean simular I mean graph does it
like similar duck because they all have
time in sight of foreigners interceptors
okay so going so okay so this was for FP
team this finite set somewhat boring so
let's go to the infinite set off because
sometimes happens and the first good
examples chordal graphs the corner
grocer exactly groves the don't have as
a new suburbs any of the cycles except
old triangle so c-45 stuff so you get a
cycle and now how you know how many ways
you can break it by adding an edge where
there are many ways but the point is
here that you need to add a lot of edges
to break completely because say you add
one edge but now after reading for
example dessert you start to have got to
shorter holes to shorter in your cyclist
given you need at the more add more
edges so feeling to triangulate this
entire cycle and there are a few Diaries
but if you look at it there's the number
of if you want to add if you have a
whole of length L the number of ways how
to triangulate is something like the
added minus one catalan number and you
had al- free edges so if you make up the
numbers you see that if you take a hole
and just branch in which out of c-
second catalan number which way you
triangulate it but then you see how how
many address you use it's something like
four to decay branching in there because
the Catalan numbers or something like to
enter then roughly
so does the branching and okay so you
can do color composition this time
because that's again the branching and
also this also works for proper interval
competition because if you look at
forbidden G sub graphs or purple
interval graphs these are essentially
already holds and a few small guys so
you ever have a small guy overhaul and
this branch and gives you some city
decay branching for printable completion
ok so from the original slide of FB t we
got almost all soft except for the
entire four guys because the interval if
you look at interval growth interval
graphs has got quite nasty
characterization by forbidden to sub
graphs well Colonel graphs are are in
particular quarter glass so they have
got all the holes are forbidden to sub
graphs but also there's something called
a tease without going to definitions the
minimal 80s are looking like this one's
so this is like a grove and there's puff
at the bottom is arbitrary long and now
look if you want to break such a guy by
adding an edge well you cannot catch
from the top guy to any guy in the
bottom and you this becomes an interval
graph so there's this huge guy and you
can break it by one edge in many
different ways I mean adding edge from
the top guy to any guy bottom and it
says problem because that means that I
mean there's like unbounded number of
ways how to fix it and using only one
actor so the typical project really
doesn't work and people where people
were a stack of this problem just like
in the graph modification commit there's
a problem for na while and if I height
was fixed it was from you solve a few
years back sit by some project strategy
but something much more clever than
before and recently we have a paper
fixing ok so we're yeah and which solves
that you can get a seat to decay
branching even with the linear time
which sounds very cool endless I would
say are we here have got very good
dependency here and keeping the linear
time that sounds awesome okay so that
seems like a closed case yes I mean we
have got the fpt our glorious most DC to
decay oh it's quite it's all brand-new
so probably even if you want to
implement it's not so bad but ok so the
next question we ask in the parameters
complexity is next question of genres in
Paris capacity is about carriers
polynomial cars can you compress the
instance tu sais pas avant que
and people ask these questions so this
first paper a site is for quarter
completion or also give some arguments
why there's prolly American I'm not sure
they really call it putting our carnal
but I mean especially you can extract
from the arguments premium are going up
there there was paper of go who treated
a few small / / dozens of Borneo
canister for completion plan if you've
considered vertex addition problems to
some graph classes or should have strong
a set of 4 billion subgraphs you get
automatically polynomial kernel because
this is SS are some heating says
instance unbounded the Phoenix instance
for edge deletion or completion problems
is not the case because a degen edge you
can create a new forbidden sub graph and
skin cascade dr I this can happen there
is a lower bound from a few years back
that shows some well a few vertex I mean
like eight vertex or 70s exactly graft
sellers completion to guy kidding to
kill all these guys actually does not
mean you're Colonel so this instance can
cascade effect in the part but yeah but
still the interesting graph classes
natural graph classes turn out mostly to
happily number Colonel these papers on
sometimes somehow involved this is
really long paper involved but they have
come but they turn out to have most
equal in America the missing thing here
is the interval completion problem and
still open here and that will cause us
some problems later in the slides ok but
so we have got multiple occurs apart
from Carol for interval completion it
since that we're mostly done and they
are we happy we can go for a beer okay
but it turned out that no no this is not
the end so okay so everything I was
talking for the last few slides was
about such as I was looking at the
characterization by forbidding sabras i
was thinking i have a whole i need to
kill a whole i have got an ID i need to
kill a 90 I've got some k2 k2 I ain't
killed Creek kill to kato but it turns
out that the other way of thinking that
I want to create a chordal graph a graph
goes through the composition has a
clique in every every back is a cake or
similar way of thinking actually it's
more fruitful and our morphol throne
gives suppressant result and there was a
paper so that 2012by from
younger that shows that actually you can
get the SAG let's finish our growing for
kroger completion and after looking for
a number of ETH lower bounds and then
that may should surprise you I mean
apart from the planner stuff which
Daniel we talked and friday we have
varied a planner like excluded minor
sparse graph causes we get very little
service functional quarries in a pity
road so that was somewhat surprised at
this point and so now my goal is to
after now my goal is to argue how you
get this type of running time using like
the approach like trying to completely
for bit about chordal graphs being
graphs that don't have holes I want to
think of color graphs as graphs that has
got like tree like structure where every
back is a click okay so let's go and so
let's go this way so what I want to do I
want to build this graph I the solution
graph so deep the this click solution of
jeep plus the added edges by dynamic
programming and the high-level idea is
that I I mean the key observations I the
key technical result of the swing is
that there is only like only sub
exponential number of reasonable like
parts in this in this dynamic
programming when I want somehow build
this click three escape three of the
completed rough by dynamic programming
and the strategy is to okay we start
with Apple animal carrier that will help
us later and we are going to enumerate
some sub exponential number of
candidates for some sort of psych
maximal cliques in the graph for example
I mean this all this Cruiser structures
will be playing around maximal cliques
and the boundary will obtain will be of
solid and the square root of case so
what we'll try to do for example the
chordal graphs is that there are only n
to the square root of K reasonable
choices for a maximal clique in the
computed graph so you're going to turn
your graph in a chordal graph there are
some maximal cliques in this choreograph
and I want to say that there's only like
n to the square root of K reasonable
things that can make be made a maximal
clique in the final graph
if I apply for an American beginnings
that means that n is polynomial in
carried and this is like something like
to do the square root of K log K so this
is like some explanation okay and from
this candidate structure from the bound
of number maximal cliques I will get a
dynamic programming algorithm okay so
now I want to spend the remaining ten
minutes maybe I got 11 mins i want to
spend 10 minutes on sketching what does
it mean to turn a card I structure in
the deepest I'd I want to sketch some
sort of like how do you prove such type
of relevance or some simple example and
spend the remaining minute unlike big
table of results we get so far okay so
let's okay so but before that I want to
buy a sort of like I don't know a flash
of what we already get so for this graph
classes I had got a developing inning we
got this running times so far so there's
like k to the square root of K we
somewhat believe I were argue on the
last slide why we believe this running
time is optimal right to the square of
care I mean after Polly logs in the
exponent for properly interval goes to
first and we don't know how to improve
we believe it should be square root of K
but we have got no idea how to improve
it ok so let's look at back at the color
completion and let's try to make the DP
and I said the cruiser structure around
the DP is the maximal click here or like
me my separator like intersection of two
neighboring maximal clique and a chordal
graph and what we get I mean we assume
that there's like only I mean what they
actually do in the paper they say that
Ivor there's some very efficient
branching step or there's only like sub
exponential number of candidate maximal
cliques for the solution graph and also
for kicks apparatus because you can
always take to maximal cliques intersect
them and say this is a candidate click
separator ok so what I want to do I want
to look at I won't take this pink
candidate so I see this pink candidate I
don't see this entire graph I just see
this pink and date I temporary delete it
from the graph in the graph speeds into
connected components ok this really
probably one connected upon violent and
this will be probably second connected
component the point is that interval
decoder completion solution the minimal
solution does not have got any incentive
to lighter once he click we fight when
this is turned into a click there is no
incentive to
glue them up together there's no hole
passing other all the holes are on the
left or the hose are on the right so it
won't add any edge from here to here
it's easy to check so essentially you
can independently solve the pink part
and solve the great part now and this
can be frightening programming state
that giving this quick separator and
pointing to one of the components like
orange one I want to find the minimum
size of a completion that in particular
turns the pink I inter click and then
you can like build this tree from the
bottom to top using DP States ok so
that's like the point is that once you
click will fight this guy I mean the
main message here is that once you turn
this pink are inter click lips connected
components of their I directs your
shoulder independently and you can do
think of the census of branching or
divine anger but the better way of doing
it that you are doing by the be up by
during programming up there okay so does
the point and others are like I mean in
same fashion I mean having this one you
can do train competition but that's not
nice so but ok so we have got this type
of result that was crucial for colder
graphs is actually was quite quick to
get from this type of result to the DB
just quite natural and but in the paper
to get there it was quite involved and I
don't have time and research here to
present it I want to give you a flavor
what's the type of arguments I and I
want to prove the following statement if
you are trying to solve interval
completion that means that you want to
add edges to get an interval graph I
want to prove that there on the end to
the square root of K reasonable
candidates for maximal cliques in this
fashion okay that's the thing that in
the next five mins I'm trying to like
give you the flavor of the proof how to
hold approved okay okay so let's look at
the interval graph this is in telegraphy
hour intervals every interval is a
vertically into if two intervals overlap
there is an edge between the vertices in
the graph okay and the maximal clique is
something like you okay you start you
start when some some interval stars and
then somewhere just take sense this is a
maximal clique in the entire graph okay
so let's define the main like every
almost every
algorithm most everyone calling in this
area starts with saying okay a cheap
vertex a vertex that has got only
squared of K at most square root of K
incident edges from the solution at the
expensive one is the one has got more
the point is that you the solutions got
only 2k end points which means that that
there are only like two squared of K
expensive guys in the search okay and I
want to indentify looking at this click
I want to define like the last chip
vertex before the click and the first
chip vertex a sturdy click like last
last endpoint of achieve verdicts and
first starting point of the chip vertex
up here okay so there's the grind green
guys and now if you look at this area
between here between the maximal clique
and the strip guy well only the
expensive guys can end here so there are
like only two squared of k ND ND guys
here let's call them dollar one and the
guys that start care needs to be
expensive let's call them delight oh
okay and the observation is here that if
you look at the guy here let's look at
this guy x here and he's in this maximal
clique and I ask myself questions why I
draw this interval in my optimization up
here to the end why I draw him up here
to the end why I didn't stop him here I
want to shorten this interval and
stopping stopping here why I cannot do
it well because there's some edge that
blocks me this edge can be over to be
one it can be able to 11 of this
expensive guys here's or it can be to
somebody lighter there I mean it can be
stretched very far away maybe it's
longer and somebody here but if it's
longer if it's up here that means that
he is no see one so let's look it's from
LA he have a nose v1 he knows one of the
expensive guys up here or he no see one
but I ver in the graph or after adding
the solution here FD not the solution so
the vertex X we straight I mean I can't
shorten the guy because he knows
somebody here on the left and that can
be indicated by ever knowing somebody
here in this area here but they're only
like I mean they're on the expensive
guys in v1 hear or knowing see one but
that means that I needed to add a
natural or to see one or there was
already one so you think this type of
program entation you can prove that
actually this maximal clique I mean
otherwise you can shorten it and save
something for example manage
next one in the solution so we can
actually show that I mean this is the
only reason for why the axis in this
ocean so like this maximal cliques it's
really like the neighborhood of v1 plus
the network of the expensive guy scares
past the neighborhood of C 1 plus the
solution neighborhood of C 1
intersection the same symmetrical
reasoning on the second side is tight
okay and that so we have the dilemma and
not the observation is that how many
choices do I have for this object is
that here well they're like and to the
four of choices for like this four
vertices here are pairing with the
expensive guys are only squared of Chi
of them so this set has like n to the
square root of K choices and these guys
were cheap so the number of incidents
ocean edges are on you're so square root
of K of them so you got like also on the
end to the square root of K choices for
this instant address and you get your
bounce n to the square root of K for the
number of candidates maximal fixer okay
okay I got three mins left so I want I
would say very brief that there are like
more problems because we don't have
pulling American also like n to the
square root of K is not fpt even for us
so we need to stick around and we do a
lot of technical cranking technical
cranking some ideas there to get there
but yeah so we eventually end with the
results saying that okay if you guess
completed edges to one vertex turn if
you the roulette them like n to the lion
little less than brute force bound on
the number of reasonable ways to choose
compression edges and we also show that
I actually can enhance the previous
reasoning to get some fpt type bound for
the number for example max analytics
okay and the second thing is that the DP
doesn't work well because if one color
graphs you we said that you can
independently solve every connected
component after you delete a clique in
interval case you got only left and
right you cannot like glue many
components to convert you got on 11
right and that means that there's
different DP and sometimes our d people
needs to go in this direction I mean
some sense right such a pyramid and like
go top to bottom lower than rest right
on such an interval graph that means
that there's a very complicated DP
similarly there and
it's not time to make it there is this
is just the time to show a number of
other results in this direction as I'm
going through the service so there is
mmm so there was a paper from I means a
bunch of people from driving on SWAT
that showed that for Speed complex
internal machinery you in just chromatic
coding and there was a paper its tax
fears back and that shows essentially
solved it's really perfect completion
paper and a few other ones but this was
the main result of their very perfect
condition is good of care is sub
exponential and we have got okay so this
is the summary of other results we have
so far so for many this gruff classes I
showed up there you got k to the square
root of K algorithm sometimes with very
nasty polynomial factors in depending on
the end but sometimes not and penny were
very happy that Karen or not apart from
proper interval that's K to the K to the
fires we don't know how to improve it
and a few similar graph classes but
naive slightly less structure in terms
of like three decomposition Republic
composition turn out to be hard under in
th to get some external corner and this
includes for example co graphs which was
quite pricey okay so that's just the
summary I want to say and I want to
finish with some apple problems so first
I mean there's one thing which we don't
know how to make squirrel there's some
tribute trade-off which would lead to KY
to the two first and we know how to
improve it may be you know how to
improve it and the second thing is you
can trash half of our paper interval
completion if you know how to do call an
attorney for this problem so that's a
good incentive I can delete like 40
pages or 30 pages of a paper for you
know how to do on your corner I would be
happy to support me recurring out there
and the question is like okay we believe
that the square root of K is the optimal
one I don't know where poly log or not I
just question about Pollock or not but I
don't know whether this lock
instabuilder or not but the thing is the
reason why we somehow don't believe ur
are skeptical about having like sub
below squared of kind exponent is that
this means that there's like sub linear
in terms of the number of vertices that
sounds really hard to be sub linear in
the number of vertices in exponent so
can you get some power bars and that's
is really hard and that's what's me how
we'll be talking about and maybe you can
have some more former explanation apart
from this graph classes corresponds to
this important parameters so this graph
has got some structural structural
properties that we can explore the why
actually this type of problems have got
service plans are going to never doped
okay thank